this is consumer genetic engineering I
think it's really going to become a
consumer industry what do I want
I want my yeast I want them to smell
like that now with them to ferment
faster v6 glow we gives people the
ability to take a gene from a jellyfish
and stick it in a yeast that they're
going to use to brew or bake or
something like that and with the FDA
everything is just no what about this no
how much of this can be allowed in there
nothing zero no no your size Ainur is a
scientist and entrepreneur who quit his
government job in a NASA lab to start a
business in his garage
so the oden is a consumer synthetic
biology company but I kind of like to
view us all as sort of like bio hacker
collective the computer hackers of the
80s and 90s transformed society at the
end of the 20th century and Dana
believes it will be do-it-yourself
genetic engineers bio hackers who will
transform it in the 21st it's going to
be a consumer industry consumers drive
like a lot of technological advancement
and if you go on the market and try to
find tools that somebody can use to do
experiments on the cutting edge of
scientific research there's no like
all-encompassing kit or guide or
protocol so what people end up doing is
they have no idea where to start his
company's first product was $150 kit
that gives amateurs access to the
cutting-edge genetic engineering tool
CRISPR but it's a nurse ultimate goal is
to put genetic modification in the hands
of the masses he needed to make things
even simpler so how do you give people
the ability to engineer something and
then be able to use it well the simplest
way to do that is yeast like yeast is
used in baking yeast is used in brewing
fermentation so many different things
enter his new product a kit allowing
anyone to make yeast fluorescent by
inserting a gene from a jellyfish
it's the CRISPR kit is akin to an
open-ended programming tool for advanced
users the yeast kit is more like a ready
to use program you download from the App
Store
consumers don't necessarily
want to build something from scratch the
majority of people just want to use it I
just want to be able to use this too it
will make a new organism several
breweries began to put the yeast app to
use right away
brewing fluorescent beer one even
offered to partner with them to create a
special blend when a local reporter
began writing up a story about the
partnership word reached the Food and
Drug Administration which gave Dana a
call and informed him he was selling an
unapproved
food additive just for your background
information anything that imparts colors
of food is considered a color additive
and under the federal Food Drug and
Cosmetic Act color additives need to
have pre-market approval by FDA they
can't technically regulate our kits
because our kits aren't food they can
only really regulate the way we market
our kit we can tell people you can get
these kits and use them to engineer
yeast and wouldn't it be cool if someday
you could use engineer used to brew
right I hypothetically in another
portion of the call the FDA tells Vayner
that he should also consider policing
how his customers used the yeast they
modify with this kit you know sometimes
what people will do is they'll put
something on their website and they'll
market it for one use but it's clear
people are buying it and using it for
another use you may want to try and keep
an eye on that it's a way that I think
kind of helped keep you out of trouble
one of the things I asked them was if I
still market this kit as used for
brewing what can you do well there's a
number of things that we can do from a
warning letter to it got to the point
where we would you know she's material I
mean I think that would be unlikely I
would hope this is who I'm dealing with
a bunch of bullies like a bunch of
people who are just out there bullying
people into doing what they want not for
scientific reasons not for the health of
the public not for the betterment of the
public just because this jellyfish
protein has been used in animal and
science research for
decades like you can literally go online
and find videos and images of whole
animals that have this protein in their
whole body not only can you find these
mice that are going green i've ingested
it people I know have ingested it we've
tested it and there's no safety concern
that we can find so like what is the
rationale behind this what happened to
Zehner is not an isolated incident but
part of an industry-wide trend if you're
an entrepreneur developing a regulated
article the cuffs are getting that
product amok are extremely high Anthony
Evans is a founder of taxa a SAN
francisco-based
synthetic biology company that aims to
create consumer products through genetic
engineering one of taxes first big
products was a glowing plant which they
aim to make bright enough to supplement
household light England and they are
currently developing fragrant moths
meant to replace conventional air
fresheners so rather than using
petroleum inputs and creating toxic
waste byproducts the moss grows in your
home and it uses sunlight carbon dioxide
and water to produce the fragrance just
the way that it's done in nature and
that gently fragrance your home the
environmental benefits of these
technologies are huge if you want to
move to a less polluting ecosystem then
biotechnology is a way together Evans
says he's had products jammed up by the
FDA and the EPA in the past and believes
that consumer synthetic biology is on
the brink of some major breakthroughs
if only government would loosen its grip
there's a product called the Arctic
Apple that just got approved by both the
FDA and the USDA remember it was 14 or
15 years in regulatory Purdue and yet we
know that most of this technology safe
that cost is coming in because you know
of the political landscape around this
not because there are actually risks
underneath if you look at two key things
that have enabled the amazing amount of
innovation that we've seen in Silicon
Valley in the last 10 20 years it is
falling costs of input back in 1999 you
needed a million dollars to create a
website and have a web server now you
need only a few thousand dollars
as costs fall then the amount of
innovation that can happen rapidly
accelerates we're seeing from a
technology perspective the same trends
happening in our field synthetic biology
it's driven by three primary
technologies the cost of reading DNA DNA
sequencing the course of writing DNA DNA
synthesis and then the one that I think
people don't necessarily recognize as
well is robotics what we're not seeing
is falling costs within regulatory
approvals so that's why a lot of
entrepreneurs are starting in the edges
right in the fringes in the places where
there aren't regulations and that makes
sense because you want to get a low-cost
market as as you can a big challenge for
startups like this is that the FDA and
EPA often require regulatory approval of
products before they go to market even
on common modifications that seem to
pose little risk and all the time you're
going through that review process you
don't even know if there's a market for
your products at the end of the day
because you're not allowed to market
it's pre-market approval that's much
more damaging to innovation in the space
because it creates an expensive in time
and money hurdle to getting something to
market Evan says that the high
compliance costs lock out most small
start-up experiments in favor of large
cash crops like corn or wheat as a
result of the cost to bring up these
products to market which are somewhere
between ten and a hundred million
dollars you can only create a product if
you think you're going to sell more than
100 million dollars worth of that
product we aren't able to measure the
number of those startups or products
that could have come to market because
by their nature their stock from ever
existing in the first place that also
has a more leveraged cost because
technology by its nature feeds on other
technology you have this exponential
growth that comes in so that you can
think of it like a network where the
amount of innovation is driven by the
connectivity of the nodes in the system
rather than just the number of nodes and
therefore when you squash out a lot of
those those nodes you're also reducing
the overall rate of progress and at the
moment we have no idea how much we're
interpreting that we just know that we
are because it's almost impossible to
launch a plant GMO company if you're
focusing on regulated articles FDA
officials declined interview requests
for this story but the agency does have
a list of generally recognized
is the safe or grass substances that
don't require free-market approval the
amount of generally recognized as safe
notices on our website and it's
ridiculously small the tests that I did
that everybody else does so these graphs
notices like allergenicity toxicity
these tests literally took me 30 minutes
2017 you're telling me I can't send you
a protein sequence and you could run
these tests yourself and you know you
have a pipeline that does it in 30
seconds the idea that just because it's
genetic engineering it's more dangerous
is completely nonsense let's take our
fragrant moss as an example explore the
scenarios that that causes harm a
healthy Mouse that's already we know is
non-toxic and it's a gene that comes
from another plant and it makes a
fragrant molecule that's in probably
every perfume on the planet we know
what's the narrative there about where
it's causing damage it's just the fear
of the unknown that says all well we
just don't know with these government
organizations their whole goal is to not
say anything that could later be used
against them so everything is just no
Evans and Zehner both continue their
work in hopes that the democratization
of science will continue allowing
innovation to just route around
government roadblock genetic engineering
is already all around us in everything
you know it's in your medicine it's in
your food it's in your children there's
nothing you can do to get away from this
the FDA they're not even at the level of
biohacking
they don't even really understand that
it's going on and I mean that's great
for like biohackers and people like me
we're effectively moving so fast we're
ahead of the regulation if the last
century was the century of physics and
the previous century was the century of
chemistry this century is going to be
the century of biology and as a result
the company the countries that create
the right regulatory environment that
submit the development of this
technology and the introduction of novel
products will gain a significant
strategic advantage and competitive
advantage over countries that don't do
that
you